[Music]
hello everybody welcome back from
titanfall 2 videos and a new dlc has
been teased by respawn on their website
if you can go check it out at respawn
com or titanfall com it's all on there
but I'm going to basically give the
quick rundown of what's going on there's
a new game mode called live flyer which
is a lightning-fast 66 pilot only mode
that brings the competitive close
quarters combat to the forefront I'm
reading this straight off of their
website basically it's a pile of a pilot
map our game mode only know like just
pilot versus pilot no Titans just pilots
and it's a very close quarters map and
there's two maps called stacks and
meadows now one of the pictures actually
has a pilot ziplining on a zipline
clearly on their website you can check
it out on their website clue if you
don't believe me but this means that the
zip line is in the game and that it can
be used in future maps the next thing
they have is in addition to the
live-fire internet dedicated maps m mode
they're also adding a brand-new
Colosseum map called columns and a new
pilot execution which they have yet to
say but they said this is a very good
one they're also adding new commander
intros for each faction so if you saw my
previous couple videos about the faction
changes I really think Reese Paul and
watch the video and listen because
everything they mentioned about that was
in that video so if that's not a
coincidence i'm happy i contributed to
this other than that basically to give
it the quick rundown there's going to be
Livefyre 66 game mode two new maps in
the new game mode a zip line through one
of the maps nu coliseum load new faction
intros new execution and lastly there's
going to be custom playlist for a custom
playlist basically it's your own it's
called make it your own mixtape let's
say you're a player that only likes
playing bounty hunting capture the flag
but you don't want to go through mixtape
and go through all the game modes let's
say you're not that and
attrition guy and do-it-yourself mixtape
you can basically make sure make your
own mixtape if once it like before your
bounty hunt and capture the flag player
you can turn off all the other game
modes but keep those two and you can
keep cycling between those game modes to
help populate the less populated game
mode excluding I think this is a great
change I think plenty of plenty of ideas
that we're throwing here this is perfect
there is no due date yet and this is
only a teaser so they haven't even
mentioned balance changes yet they
haven't even mentioned anything else
just this is just a teaser like I said
before there is no due date on this but
I hope you all did enjoy the super quick
video I really want to get this out so
we're going to end it here have a great
day guys in peace out